Olivier nous rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales pour la famille
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur général mes chers
collègues pour l'exercice 2022 la
branche famille sera en excédent de 2,6
milliards d'euros il se réduirait de
moitié en 2023 pour atteindre 1,3
milliards d'euros cette à moindrement de
l'excédent résulte pour 850 millions
d'euros de la décision bienvenue du
gouvernement de revaloriser de moitié la
location de soutien familiale en faveur
des parents isolés c'est l'une des rares
lueurs de ce PLFSS pour les 70% restants
la baisse provient du transfert la CNAV
de la charge des indemnités journalières
du congé postnatal de maternité cette
mesure grève les dépenses de 2 milliards
d'euros sans que les familles n'y
trouvent concrètement le moindre
avantage la trajectoire financière plus
annuelle de la branche
fortement affecté avec un excellent
réduit à 500 millions en 2025 privant la
branche famille des moyens d'une
ambition nouvelle c'est pourquoi
l'initiative de la rapporteur général la
commission vous proposera de supprimer
ce transfert de charge
s'agissant des articles concernant la
branche famille se belfss concentre ce
concentre sur la réforme de complément
de libre choix du mode de garde de 10
CMG le CMG est emploie direct compense
aux familles le coût de la garde de
leurs enfants
âgé de moins de 6 ans lorsqu'elle
recourt à une assistante maternelle ou à
une personne salariée pour une garde à
domicile le barème actuel induit des
effets de seuil important et provoque
des restes à charge élevés pour les
foyers aux revenus les plus modestes il
rend quasiment impossible le recours à
un mode de garde individuel pour ces
familles et donc c'est une fracture
sociale et ce n'est pas juste l'article
36 propose donc de remédier à ces
difficultés en déterminant désormais le
CMG en fonction ressources de la famille
du nombre d'enfants à charge du nombre
d'heures et du coup médian de la Garde
dès lors les taux d'efforts des familles
s'égaliseraient à la manière de la
participation demandée pour un accueil
en crèche relevant de la prestation de
service unique d'ipsu l'article 36
prévoit aussi la possibilité pour les
familles monoparentales de recevoir le
CMG emploi direct jusqu'au 12 ans de
leurs enfants contre 6 ans pour le droit
commun autre lueur la commission soutien
la réforme proposée du CMG qui
correspond aux attentes des familles
elle a en outre adopté un amendement
visant la suspension sans délai du
versement du CMG aux familles cessant de
rémunérer l'assistante maternelle ou la
garde à domicile mais mais il y a un
mais l'article 36 suscite plusieurs
regrets à commencer par son entrée en
vigueur prévu tardivement pour juillet
2025 d'autre part il aurait sans doute
été possible une évolution du barème
accompagnée d'un mécanisme de
compensation plus satisfaisant en l'état
du texte 43% des bénéficiera actuel du
CMG serait défavorisés à l'application
de la réforme qu'est-il proposé à ces
familles perdantes l'article prévoit un
complément compensatoire aux paramètres
incertains et placer sous conditions de
ressources et au recours minimal au mode
de garde la réforme se fera donc bel et
bien au détriment de certaines familles
déjà déjà engagés auprès d'une
assistante maternelle ou d'une garde à
domicile une seconde mesure prévue à
l'article 37 oblige l'employeur à verser
aux salariés en lui et place des cpams
une somme au moins égale aux indemnités
journalières pour congés de maternité
d'adoption ou de paternité l'employeur
serait ainsi subroger dans les droits
des assurés de percevoir les indemnités
si certains employeurs ont choisi
librement cette option ou applique la
matière un accord de branche
une telle obligation légale de versement
semble disproportionner en raison des
charges de trésorerie qu'elle fait peser
aux entreprises
un disquement de leur taille ou de leur
situation la commission vous proposera
donc de supprimer cette disposition
comme vous le constaterez mes chers
collègues de nombreux autres mesures
attendues et familles sont absentes de
ce plfs je pense à la réforme de la
prestation partagée d'éducation de
l'enfant la prépare ou à la fin de la
modulation des allocations familiales
selon les revenus le retour à
l'université
mesure votée par le Sénat en février
dernier il convient aussi de s'atteler à
la création de place en crèche
attendu par les familles
indispensables pour l'égalité
homme-femme et puis pour ce qui concerne
une emploi ipliabilité plus forte
notamment des femmes et aux difficultés
de recrutement des professionnels de la
petite enfance qui est chaque jour plus
important on parle de 10000
places disponibles 10000 places
attendues toutes ces avancées ne se
feront pas sans coût financiers c'est
pourquoi nous devons préserver les
marches de manœuvre budgétaires de la
CNAV pour une relance véritablement
ambitieuse de la politique familiale je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Philippe mouillé rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales pour
l'autonomie pour 5 minutes